the wolf I think is just incredible you
can see the details and of the boot me
the couple are very special I love just
as much as the front the way jacket
draped over one shoulder you can really
see the material like how it's been
formed and made interacts with the
lights of your create shadows your your
pockets as well when you're in this
space you are drawn to look at the
ceiling you know that's the signature I
think that's why I put a series of
lights
bounced off this disk so you have the
light bouncing off in directly onto the
sculptures I think like activates them
it kind of brings another life to the
sculpture I was very intrigued by laughs
and another killzone he has these
touches of them of conservation he's
quite dirty
in fact some who have also been kind of
graffitied and I really asked if we
didn't dust or clean any of the
sculptures because I just really wanted
them to be literally something that
she's taken and placed I was intrigued
because he's lost his finger to so he's
calling you but you know he has nothing
and I made each of the Flint's before
the sculptures if you think about
medieval sculptures they used to have
like painted kind of surfaces but I kind
of thought about the sculpture and came
up with the color in relationship to the
sculptures each one has a different
sense of gaze which is very concentrated
on her shell is obviously staring out
Martyn stone and the couple are very
intertwined it's a sculpture for me and
it was really hard to think about the
size of the wall I didn't want it to be
too big it's also something to enable a
passage in the space so that's why you
have this and you have two sides to this
to the wall the front and the back which
are equally important to me in the front
is a very laborious process because the
wall is made actually of old plaster the
plaster man who made this his his a
craftsman and there's not so many of
them about anymore actually it was
really hard to find him
he worked over the summer in his studio
to make the mold and then came in with
his crew and it was like a jigsaw puzzle
to assemble the wall it's creating a
backdrop for the sculptures
important you'll you'll then see the
other side they're not polish side it's
really the process you also discover the
film is really a work could light again
each of the four sculptures appear in
the film actually makes you kind of
think again how you're looking at them
so then maybe I'll go back and look at
them or maybe you won't that it's like
him is introducing them when you see
this work there are so many
conversations that are not seen in a way
it was the conservators interest and
their support that really enabled me to
borrow the sculptures and they really
were interested in the connection
between historical artworks and
contemporary art